fire officials say today some evacuation
warnings have been lifted in parts of el
dorado county meanwhile the hard rock
hotel is welcoming first responders as
its guests including a crew from the
reno fire department victor park has our
story
it is a sea of red fire trucks taking
over the glamour of the hard rock hotel
in state line but crews from reno
modesto san diego and even colorado
aren't here to gamble i'm going to go
get some sleep get some dinner hotel
staff wouldn't let us record inside but
beyond these walls first responders are
doing more than just resting the hotel
has been transformed into their home and
work office we were told that the the
firefighters were going to be
using the hard rock as a command center
call it a fire station or a command
center this is a place providing meals
every night they are also showing a
movie it's an effort to make these crews
feel at home keep in mind they work
24-hour shifts breathing in the
unhealthy smoke battalion chief bill
erlac with reno fire says there are
about 20 firefighters from his
department if fires are out in more
remote areas we ended up basically
sleeping out in the dirt as you can
imagine no kids go to sleep you're
constantly in the smoke which is less
beneficial for your sleeping habits
so it is awesome to get into hotel rooms
awesome it is when you know there are
people not taking firefighting efforts
for granted we're not in a revenue
generating mode right now we're
completely in a support mode and our
team members that are staying here
actually helping keep the operation
going so our firefighters have a place
to come back to and it's not just a
place for crews to come back to staff
say 40 percent of the guests are
families of their home most forced to
evacuate too we're doing what we can as
a community try and help out because it
is a community united living up to its
words of tahoe strong covering the story
i'm victor park
as of right now the kaldor fire has
burned around 215 thousand acres and is
now 43 percent contained